are you on the right path I got a great
question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys salah who wrote in to say
thank you evan for the videos i have a
question for you how do you know if
you're on the right or wrong path to
achieve your dream keep it up this is a
fantastic question and one that causes a
lot of doubt a lot of fear for people
this is the difference between thinking
with your head and following your heart
ok this is this is such an important
question because when you're looking for
proof for evidence for data to back up
what you're doing to know that you're on
the right path you're thinking with your
head right show me the proof show me
that it's working give me the three
things right you're looking for data and
evidence you're thinking logically with
your head where all of the best most
important biggest decisions that you
ever make with your life should come
from your heart and not your head it's
so important and often those two things
will fight they'll conflict what your
heart says to do is different than what
your head says to do the reason why you
always trust your heart instead of your
head is because your head can only make
decisions on on a world that exists you
look at the data the stats the numbers
and you say here's what I'm going to do
next where your heart can lead you to a
path that doesn't make sense but you
find a way to make it work because you
creating a new world you create a new
world of opportunities that didn't exist
before so the data will say don't do
that it hasn't worked for anybody but
your heart says I can make this happen
that's what successful entrepreneurs do
every single time when they've launched
their business you look at you look at
the most successful entrepreneurs in the
world you look at the early days of
their business the data would have said
don't do that that's stupid even their
friends to family right the little man
in their life will tell them don't do
this it doesn't
make sense but their heart tells them to
do it so they have to keep going when I
first started helping entrepreneurs I
did this this presentation at the YMCA
and some of you may have heard this
story already but I did all this
promotion I got all excited they were
promoting I was promoting it was a free
event I was so excited to come and
deliver a presentation to a couple
hundred people and three people showed
up three people I was my I was so
devastated I felt like a total failure I
felt like I wasted my time but I still
gave my presentation and I made an
intimate and I really helped those three
people today I felt so good by the end
of it I felt like wow this was so great
I have to find a way to keep doing this
I felt alive in that moment and I knew I
had to find a way to keep doing this
even though what's the logical thing
right what would the logical thing beat
it would be to look and say listen look
you promoted this for a couple weeks the
ymca point this for a couple weeks it
was a free thing and all you got was
three people to come out how could this
ever become a business for you this is a
stupid idea go get a job where you know
you're going to make X amount of dollars
every month you can't turn this into a
business and yet that might be what my
head is telling me that my heart feels
like you know I have to find out I have
to find a way to keep doing this because
I love it because this makes me come
alive so how do you know if you're on
the right path it's not it's not how
much dollars are coming in it's not how
many people are visiting your website
it's not quantifiable it's here do you
wake up excited for what you're going to
do today do you feel like you're having
an impact have you found something that
makes you come alive if you have then
you're on the right path believe for
those you watch like the video thumbs up
below leave a comment let me know what
you think ask me a question I make your
video response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel and see more
videos like this thank you so much and
I'll see you soon
you